This is the last and final season.
What, how is everyone gonna cope
without a show that is so representative of life?
"This Is Us" is about everyone.
Brilliant title too, because it brings everyone in.
It is a great title.
It's better than the untitled Dan Fogelman project
which it was when I auditioned for it.
(Drew laughing)
So "This Is Us",
what he landed on was that
our creator, Dan Fogelman really wanted to create a show
where everybody could see themselves.
And I remember people asking me
when did you know you had a hit?
And, but I remember around episode four or so
which was "The Swimming Pool".
And I had a cousin of mine call me
and she's a plus sized woman.
She was adopted. Right?
And she said, Sterling
I know you're real excited about this OJ thing you just did.
'Cause I had just done that.
But she said, this "This Is Us",
she says, this show is church.
It is therapy.
It is healing.
She says, I see myself in Kate and Kevin and Randall.
Like the way that this show affects my life,
it's like you're saving me money on therapy
by virtue of coming into my home every Tuesday
and allowing me to process all this stuff
that has happened in the past.
I don't know what we'll do without it.
I'm sure something else will come along that is lovely.
I'm gonna miss it.
We're gonna miss telling the story of the Pearson family.
And I know I've talked to your producers about this whatnot.
The good thing that I feel about the show
is that Fogelman always wanted to do six seasons.
So he had a beginning, middle and end
that he wanted to like see this thing through with.
And so we're not gonna have anything that like
goes on in perpetuity and hopefully we'll finish stronger.
I hesitate to say this 'cause I love the show
but we will finish stronger than "Game Of Thrones".
All right.
So I came across the article where you talked about
sticking the landing and how you went to Dan Fogelman
and said, we have to stick this landing.
How are you feeling about it right now?
I'm feeling really good.
I feel like it's gonna be awesome.
(audience clapping)
I'm picturing like a 10 stick,
like all the judges, a 10 and that perfect landing,
because I'm so glad that you aspire that.
It is important.
And that you have your eye on the prize with that
is so money and I'm just so excited to see it.
Okay, when we come back,
Sterling K Brown is going to bare it all.
"This Is Us" secrets and more.
Don't go anywhere.
(upbeat music)